Good Fellas my dad was just watching
Good Fellas and I've said this on the
Pod before but they opened the trunk and
they stabbed the guy yes yes stabbings
are not cool for some reason guns seem
so fake yeah it's stabbing he probably
really was stabbing something it sounds
yeah because it's the sound and all that
Foley guy in a quiet Studio stabbing
like lamb chops just being like is that
juicy enough yeah crazy I don't know if
I've done anything yet oh I meant for
you for you I wouldn't do what you mean
for me oh for me what's traumatizing to
me yeah no like those little things that
your dad or your mom probably didn't
know my mom used to put me in a closet
and shoot dope outside okay so
there's stuff like that you know that
stop it you can't follow my Good Fellas
yeah so